here's a really weird voicemail or
voicemail number of course to 192 david
p take a listen to this strange
voicemail about my relationships with
older men i don't know what this is
about
david um you have been very open about
your sort of your relationship with much
older men i mean you're talking about
men twice and you know that sometimes
three times your own age you're seeing
and i just wanted to say you know you're
such an american hero for doing that
days i just want to yell personally
thank you for coming out and being so
honest with your audience and some
people would say you know it's
completely inappropriate to be
discussing these sort of things on a
radio politics talk show program but all
right you know what if i'm not one of
those people i just want to personally
thank you for being so open and honest
about your homosexuality and uh i wish
you the best in the future thank you i
don't know what you're talking about but
I appreciate the kind wishes we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
become a member become a patron to get
instant access to that bonus show